is time for screen junkies movie vibes
this episode of movie fights is brought
to you by mortal engines in theaters
December 14th what's going on everybody
oh yeah there's a nice close shot of my
mustache welcome to movie fights hashtag
movie fights and I want to give a shout
out to all the goo hooligans out there
what's going on owl nation
hoot hoot where my owls at oh hello
Percival why hello all right this is
movie fights and this is an exciting one
you guys because the winner of today's
movie fights will go on to a title match
versus the one and only Dan Merle our
movie fights champion let's meet our
competitors
Oh first up hiding behind the screen
junkies fans dome card looking for his
camera he's a good friend of the family
he is a comic book writer extraordinaire
Captain America Wonder Woman Santo
salmon's - oh thanks man and he's an
Eisner Award winner mark and Draco whoo
yeah Marc how goes it great end of the
year so wrapping it up open it up going
ready to hibernate for a couple of
months there you go just as all bears do
okay Laurie should not have said that
you walked right into it
next up oh you know from DC all-access
she's a great friend of the family and a
super badass movie fighter Clark wolf
thank you guys for having me
what a treat oh he's a treat to have you
Clark uh yeah very excited to be here
and also excited because when you put
your first name in the first name of our
third and final competitor together you
get Clark Gregg
but yes no one from agents of shield is
here today but we have an awesome movie
fighter and a great friend of the show
Greg Alba my friend yes good to have you
grind excited to be here I respect these
two a lot I see them all the time on the
internet so and this is very it's like
the most relaxed movie fight stabilize
everything apart so chill right now yeah
which is great for a fight yeah and we
calm your names in to us the names of
all movie fighters into a supercomputer
named Jack Shipley and it's been out of
here three as our top three contenders
so you're all awesome I cannot wait to
get this movie fight started a massive
throwdown and deciding the winners of
each question and all of the points will
be myself and long Dan calling lon
Harris on the facts what's going on long
oh not too much just check in all the
facts reading what people are saying
about this show nothing yet but it'll
come to you as a good friend and to you
and the voice of the people she will be
the conduit of the online poll letting
us know what your thoughts on each
question is Daniel Radford yes so I am
the voice of the people that is me so
the way that works is we have an
official poll on YouTube the poll or all
of the answers will go up after the
fighters have given their initial
arguments because we want this to be
about the arguments not about which one
you like better once that goes up go
ahead and vote and in the case of a tie
between judges that becomes our
tiebreaker but we'll make sure that we
read that off either way also there's
lots of like fun stuff to do on the
movie fights live hash tag I highly
suggest you guys go in there and add
some stuff because I am trying to make
sure that I'm getting as much of it as I
can and if you bang creams meanness yes
means please give us all the good things
all of your answers alternate stuff and
if you have any questions about how the
poll works go ahead and ask em in the
chat all right Thank You Danielle
Radford so again this is a best-of-seven
game the first player to achieve four
points wins there are three regular
round questions and then the top two
combatants will move into the speed
round and then it's anybody's ballgame
you can be down
reow and the speed round and make a
furious comeback it has happened before
I think ok and before we get started I
just want to thank mortal engines for
bringing you this episode of movie
fights mortal engines it's an epic
adventure from the filmmakers of Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit adapted from
the award-winning book series by Philip
Reeve it follows Hester Shaw a
mysterious young woman who is the only
one that can stop London now a giant
predator city on wheels from devouring
everything in its path you can see
mortal engines in theaters and IMAX on
December 14th
yeah yes trailer looks kind of badass
and I'm not gonna lie right there cool
stuff going on alright so as we said the
number one title the number one
contender is on the line here and that
contender will step into a one-on-one
movie fight against Dan Merle and I
believe someone said that the champion
might be in the house so what yes hello
Ike I have to recuse myself today
because it wouldn't be fair for me to be
judging potentially my one of you three
will be fighting for the belt but you
are all chosen because you've been on
the show lately and kicking a lot of
butt so congratulations and I look
forward to fighting one of you there's
no easy choice so yeah I'm gonna go
watch this fight but I wanted to say hi
before we before we started it's gonna
be a good time and how I love doing
Bohemian Rhapsody this is her GTE yes
mean it well he didn't ask me but I'm
gonna move that all right uh you know
what jte dropped that sickest package
[Music]
I love it alright guys or every time so
let's settle this once and for all big
question right out of the gate who's the
greatest action hero character in movie
history
history and we start with player number
one mark M Draco I went with the
grandfather of them all James Bond he's
been in over 20 films now and has been
around since the late 50s I believe dr.
know was published in everything goes
back to him we wouldn't have Mission
Impossible without him you can tell
because MI is the abbreviation for
Mission Impossible which is also mi the
organization which Bond is from um it's
a character that has succeeded being
multiple actors so many other action
movie characters are so married to the
performer this character can be
reinvented he's sort of like Batman
without a costume you can always
reinvent him and we've been stealing
from these spy movies since they
originated and he's still valid today
he's even more successful than he was
when he first appeared in film alright
mark and Draco coming out of the gate
with James Bond so go over to Clark wolf
yes okay well um so I I went a little
different on this one for the greatest
action movie character I picked leia
organa now I I know that it's easy for
people to sort of write her off as a
love interest some of the lines the
iconic costumes like those are the
things that we talk about when we talk
about Leia but when I went back and
revisited these films it was amazing to
me how prolific and action-packed her
arc has been she has been in the fight
since the beginning and the thing that
really stands out to me the most about
her is that she in addition to being a
ground breaking character in a an iconic
series one of the most popular series of
all time she actually got to have an arc
we watched this character this fighter
start as a princess who is green and in
over her head and evolved into a general
a general who is using her skill set
who's still in the battle and still in
the fight even
decades later to to sort of fight for
the things that she that she believes in
so I I'm a big fan of the leia organa
character and that's why I picked her
Thank You Clark all right player number
three gregg allman my pick is sir Ethan
Hunt I've run the mission impossible
franchise was he knighted in my mind
here's okay to me he's the whole package
he's charming expert at hand-to-hand
combat expert with weapons gadgets but
he's not solely reliant on it he can
read lips - that's a nice plus he's a
killer on the motorcycle as you can see
in that photo and he could have on most
things on his own but he's also a great
team leader I feel like a lot of the
times action heroes are more just art
types and not really characters and what
this franchise has done so well and
uniquely done well is that you learn
about Ethan Hunt through his actions
he's constantly presented obstacles
where he has a mission and and then
there's like an innocent person in
danger and he'll take the time to save
that person pull us go through insane
obstacles like clearly we're on him he's
very human to complete that mission he
cares about more than just the mission
he cares about the world and he cares
about the ones around him and you'll
never see Ethan Hunt do one of those you
know like greater good sacrifices at the
expense of the ones he loves and the
innocent people around him yet he still
completes the mission plus you know it's
Tom Cruise so there's always a real
sense of danger and tension in the
action in the stunt moments because you
really feel like this Ethan Hunt is the
closest thing we'll have to a real-life
action hero spy and because of that out
of all these choices Ethan Hunt is a
character here with the most memorable
death-defying action sequences which Tom
Cruise manages to top with each new
installment as well as enriching the
character with each installment slug it
out fighters I think Leia is a fantastic
character and I think I was she got to
give a shout out to Gloria Katz who just
died it was the uncredited co-writer of
Star Wars who fought for Leia who did
all the great stuff for Leia
which was awesome that George Lucas even
back then was woke but I don't
necessarily think of her as an action
star I think of her as a character and
she's so married to Carrie Fisher I
don't think I don't ever think we're
gonna in our lifetime gonna see someone
else play her we've done animation and
video games yes but
the image is she's so ingrained and Jen
Ethan Hunt is an American version of
James Bond Mission Impossible was a TV
series inspired by James Bond he
wouldn't exist without I don't think
that makes him the best I don't think
[ __ ] makes James Bond the best oh just
because he started I feel like Ethan
Hunt especially in the films is a major
improvement over I think
bond is actually like pretty overrated I
think bonds boring I think he's more of
an archetype and not a real character oh
this is a great his pay his wife was
murdered there's so much it there's more
that's not really explored though and
that's not really felt nothing really
explored or felt with Tom Cruise in
those months totally disagreed addition
impossible three that's like so personal
and intense but at first ten minutes is
better than any bond part because
where's you're saying that James Bond
feels like an archetype Tom Cruise feels
like I'm watching Tom Cruise in a movie
he's charismatic and he's absolutely a
movie star but I watched that and I see
Tom Cruise playing a role I never
believed I never felt Ethan Hunt was a
real three-dimensional character now if
even if lay ahead all his action scenes
she'd she'd be the one to win
she's arguably one of the most important
female characters in the history of film
especially in genre because it was
always raised a forest and the women in
totally but I just don't I don't know
like if she fits in yeah and I figured
that this was gonna come up actually in
this conversation and that's part of the
reason why I wanted to do this fight
with her because when you go back and
you watch those movies
it's amazing how nitty-gritty she gets
in there it's Leia the facilitates
Luke's rescue of HA luke's rescue at the
end of empire layer rescues Han from
Carbonite she's the one who see it's
funny cuz when we think of Leia we think
of her in the sexy gold bikini but what
does she do in my gold bikini she
[ __ ] strangles the hell out of Java
and gets in there I also feel it's fun
to watch at the end of empire watch Leia
Lando literally has to pull her away
from the conflict so I think that what's
hard is that we when we think about her
she's been so ingrained in pop culture
as you know this iconic figure but it's
amazing because she really does have
those action sequences it's not the
action sequences like you guys have
right with motorcycles and jumping off
of things and death-defying stunts but I
think
you guys actually made the argument for
why each of your character is characters
are kind of the weaker characters in
this argument you know and so I actually
agree with the notion is about action
hero though right I think there's an
argument to be made that Leia is an
action hero but she's certainly not the
best action hero of all time I think she
is I know these movie fights you gotta
say that but it's not true she's the
reason why I think she was she arguably
is one of the greatest action heroes of
all time in addition to being an
action-packed franchise and doing all
the things that I just mentioned all of
those examples of when she actually got
into the action we see the evolution of
her as an action hero we see you know
with both respectively with Ethan Hunt
and with James Bond I don't want to see
60-year old men you know still jumping
off of cliff cliffs and acting like this
is at all relatable I like that the
evolution of Leia's action hero is that
she's a general and she is in the fight
but not in the same way that she was
when a young woman when she was a young
woman which I think demonstrates a
mature arc for James were here I think
she's a good leader but that doesn't
make her a good action hero necessarily
and I think she's an amazing character I
think she's definitely one of the best
science fiction characters gender aside
up there but I don't think when I think
when you have asked the average person
action hero I don't think Princess Leia
is gonna be in the top ten even with
snot worse if you think alike you know
Han Solo or Luke Skywalker be the
problem thank you for illustrating that
point as well for me it's not about
gender I just don't think there's enough
when I think of Princess Leia I don't I
think of a couple of moments I think of
the help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my
only hope
I think it for strangling job but when
you when you say Ethan Hunt or when you
say James Bond you think of these big
action the events action is integral to
who they are she's a much I think she's
probably the smartest of all three of
these characters but I don't think
that's the question it's not the
question but I just have to keep going
back to the fact that we have been fed
over decades clip reels and you know
pounding into our heads lay
in certain ways but I am telling you
that if you re watching Empire if you re
watch return in the Jedi Leia is in the
fight and she has those action moments
but we don't celebrate them and we don't
talk about them because the way that
Leia is framed in our memories they're
not that impactful though those action
moments are not the big takeaways and I
think murdering Java isn't important
that's I mean I would I would certainly
disagree really think that if you like
look at force awakens and you see the
job that all like Han Luke and Leia have
done but if they're action heroes
they're clearly not good at their jobs
because nothing's changed since they
like since Leia became oh that's that's
a dr. political issue I mean that's
that's a political issue within the
world of Star Wars that's not what we're
talking about today but in talking about
the actions that Leia doesn't it like
them things you memorize about it and I
think to what James Bond I just don't
think I think the world around bond is
better than the character a bond bond is
cloud or same thing about Ethan Hunt I
would not I feel simply mission
impossible what do you think about when
you go to all those movies you think
about time you think about Ethan Hunt do
the I think about way more than that I
mean Mission Impossible 3 is probably my
favorite personal one because of the
fact of how intense and emotionally
personal that is you don't get that with
any of the bond
I mean with even like long days see when
you went personal with Ethan Hunt and
made the franchise better and it kept
getting better you went personal with
Bamba Casino Royale that was good but
ever since then the Bond franchise has
been confusing they don't know what to
do with it
I think the gadgets and stuff rakul but
Ethan Hunt is multi-skilled he's great
at working with people and the fact that
it's Tom Cruise that you associate with
him proves how nuanced it is you could
pretty much pause the blu-ray right here
and shift gears move into final thoughts
okay mark and Draco's darkness off I
don't think I don't think you thought
hunt will be a character after me after
Tom Cruise retires I think that
character is so integrally genetically
attached to Tom Cruise and I don't think
I think Tom Cruise is personality bring
stuff
I think Leia is a great character but in
my mind the additives of in front of her
name action is not one of the top five
without James Bond so much wouldn't
exist in the fact that his movies still
make billions of dollars today or
they're more successful than ever shows
that he's a character that can be
reinvented and be viable forever for
everyone else I think his
so I think he's the father of even huh
that'll be a great for a nice crossover
action okay as James Bond Ethan hunts
daddy Clark yes okay so let's go back to
I think what the other two competitors
are trying to do to to break apart my
argument action hero right I firmly
believe that you have to ask yourself
the question what makes a hero and and
then on top of that what makes a
complete action hero with both of the
other two franchises you get glimpses
and glimmers into actual character an
actual story but at the end of the day I
feel like the stunts probably overshadow
what could make those characters
compelling and interesting and with
somebody like Leia once again I've
already cited examples of her getting
into the action and fighting but at the
end of the day Leia to me is a complete
action hero we're on top of the cool
spectacle and on top of getting into the
fray we see an actual and realistic
evolution and arc of an action hero
meaning we watch her age gracefully and
see how her being involved in the action
it changes and grows into a more
realistic portrayal frankly with her
becoming in general Thank You Clark
Gregg I mean if you want to talk about
action hero and though the one character
here who actually has sequences that
people really remember and are really
impactful fide and actually feel the
intensity of it Mission Impossible three
the running chase scene all the debye
sequences in Ghost Protocol the
motorcycle chase scenes in rogue nation
the underwater sequence fall out the
helicopter chase but beyond just the
physical action scenes where he's the
only one here who we really believe is
capable of all these things I think the
fact that Tom Cruise is the only one who
plays him proves a level of nuance any
good-looking guy with decent acting
chops who can do a British accent and
maybe get a little more physically fit
can play James Bond it's really a
OneNote character who's like a
misogynistic womanizing alcoholic he's
not a very interesting dude and Princess
laya for me she was really good for her
time but she's not the action hero we're
not even really thought of to be one she
doesn't flash to mind as an action here
just because she's iconic doesn't mean
that you're gonna go oh she's the action
hero of that franchise bond to me is one
note Ethan Hunt demonstrates a variety
of so many skills plus he has leadership
qualities bond doesn't work well with
others Ethan Hunt knows how to solely
rely on himself and he and he
demonstrates all those qualities hey
mark I do demonstrate all those
qualities and just because I like you're
talking about bond came first but it's
like Bruce Lee came before a Jackie Chan
but I think Jackie Chan's fight scenes
are better than Bruce Lee that doesn't
necessarily mean that oh I think Bruce
Lee's a better fighter but I think
Jackie Chan's Fighting's a better same
thing I would stay with Ethan on I think
bonds a terrible spy he always says his
name and he also always gets caught he
always gets caught I think Ethan Hunt is
actually someone who proves he's a damn
good spy he doesn't shoot first and then
ask questions later he actually does spy
work any more hot takes
ring-a-ding-ding that's round one all
right the pinyon based game it sure is
it sure is feel free to add Greg about
that Bruce Lee stuff all right
foul nation yes thank you sir hashtag
alum nation law and facts what's going
on a few a few facts mostly to confirm
actually uh mark said that dr. Noah was
first published in 1958 or 59 he was
right on the money it was 1958 he also
said doctor note like the the Bond films
are making more money than they ever
have before
it is also correct doctor no grossed
about 16 million in 1968 that works out
today to about a hundred and sixteen
million dollars
Spectre gross 200 million into 2015 so
the bond fills our more popular
internationally today than they were
when they first came out Ethan Hunt is
not a knight everybody thank and the
last thing about Bruce Lee versus Jackie
Chan I would encourage our viewers to
sound off about that in the comments
it's a it's a
I'll give you a branch phone number if
you want yeah but right on thank you on
alright let's talk about this mark I'm
gonna talk about it first that means not
gonna win the point yeah I'm here soon
next year this is this seat as always
yeah James Bond a great character I just
feel like there wasn't quite enough
there like he started at all that
doesn't mean he's the best and I think
Greg hit you on he was a little bit
OneNote and also like some of the in the
final thoughts the stuff about him being
a misogynistic alcoholic like you could
there's a lot of stuff written about
that that's really interesting that
could also take him down a peg great
character I love all the bonds but yeah
you're not gonna take it so it came down
to Clark and Greg from it for me Clark
it felt to me like you were trying to
fit a round peg into a square hole and
but then you started to sell me you
really started to open my eyes onto like
how big of the arc and what kind of
character she is and she does just get
put in this box as love interest and
people don't respect the journey so you
really open my eyes to the journey but
when I go back to the question who is
the greatest action hero character in
movie history um to me she is not that
even though you opened my eyes I feel
like they kind of dinged you on that and
to the very essence of the question it's
Greg yeah you sold me on several
different levels including like yeah
you're like just what you took as a
negative
it's just Tom Cruise Tom cruising around
but he's putting his body on the line
and Greg say like the way Greg said it
makes viewing it more that much more
compelling so people are not making
James Bond movies and the stunts so that
that's not a really valuable overhanging
okay yeah Greg gets it for me long
pretty good argument on a huge James
Bond fan he would have been my pick out
of all three of these answers but yeah I
sort of agree with you how I feel like
Mark could have made a stronger case and
Greg was really crapping on the
character I I wanted you to come back
and more forcefully I kind of
you know he was he was the first but
also here's all of these sort of
archetypal things that bond sort of put
in place III didn't necessarily hear a
lot of that so it did come down to Clark
versus Greg for me I gotta be honest I
wasn't really too swayed by the like
she's not an action character like yes
you know she's not doing stunts she's
not jumping out of things like Tom
Cruise but she's a woman of action and I
really liked clerks arguing about how
you know her sort of grow through this
year she becomes a general she's like
the leader at the end so even though not
a conventional pick I'm going with Clark
okay
and there we go yeah jte thank you for
taking that point back from Greg's
Florida oh my gosh
okay so we are locked up at one one and
the audience is going to decide Danielle
audience is gonna say all right well
with 52 percent it is even 29 percent
James Bond and 17 percent
give me that point GT sweet vindication
for jay-z so one of the comments and I
saw that on Twitter now we had a lot of
people very heavily we had some indiana
jones' one i really liked was at
Amelia's dad Jer who said greatest
action hero in movie history Snake
Plissken is doing the madness with half
the eyes yeah then one fifteenth of the
movies yeah that's a great one I mean I
yeah there's so many
I love Ripley from aliens JT ease I saw
that tweet come through Rambo that's a
classic one yeah a lot of good ones out
there I'm buying Paige rivet you know
who actually is it's Ethan Hunt and Greg
takes a 100 I into round number two all
right mark and Clark looking to get on
the board mark and Clark yes yes d isn't
needed all right so with Halloween
child's play Friday the 13th and now
news of Candyman don't say his name five
times all getting revivals
what horror franchise should be buried
for good and that means no more sequels
no reboots no revivals we are done with
that franchise forever which one do you
want to see go away and we're gonna
start with player number two for
question number two Clark okay so I went
with scream for this one
you know the reason actually for me is
threefold
first of all story wise I think that
scream is so tied to Sidney Prescott as
a character and I don't see any reason
why the ghost face mask because as we
know the killers are all different in
there I know but I didn't say who they
were
haha so you just know they're not the
same person over and over again but so
the mask is is sort of the ghost face
the gospace villain and and that to me
is not a compelling enough reason to
continue the franchise forward in
addition to that from a business
perspective I think that we've seen that
whether it's on film or on television
they just you know it's not working
audiences just aren't here for it you
know when you're talking about these
slasher movies that are being rebooted
whether it's Michael Mayer or Halloween
or it's right into the 13th these are
characters that are you know haunting
that are haunting the the final girl
whereas with scream it's it's it's just
the mask and finally out of respect Wes
Craven is so does it and this is a
personal preference but I do think it's
a compelling argument for why I think we
should be done with scream and that's
Wes Craven I think is as tied to that
franchise as Kevin Williamson the writer
is and and Wes Craven has passed on he
directed all of the scream films and I
think we see without his touch and
creative influence you know the show's
is just lackluster so I think that we're
done with scream thanks Clark Greg I'm
going with the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
there was only one good movie out of
this entire franchise that's not that
one on the screen right now I know and
out of eight of those movies I think
there was eight you can fact check me
there there was only one other one that
was okay
and that was the remake of the good one
as the only okay one I'll say the best
thing to follow up the first the
original Texas Chainsaw that was good
was the teaser trailer for the remake
which did you guys remember that it's
like not in the movie but it's awesome
that's the only good thing was that the
one with the sound effect yeah all the
Texas Chain Saw films are the exact same
you know it's young people usually on
some kind of road trip who encounters
some cannibal Hicks who are in love with
their creepy son Leatherface and even
when they have a setup that seems like
it's something new they always evolve
into the exact same movie and I think
there and there is I saw the most recent
one that came out last year and no one
saw that one but me oh you saw it okay
and most people didn't see it it made
like no money every time you think this
franchise is dead they they keep
bringing it back for some reason and yet
if you go I'm like even Rotten Tomatoes
critics and audience score all around
after the first one are just it's just
bad it's bad it's not good should be
ended and no ideas no more ideas thanks
Greg mark I was gonna pick the Madea
franchise but then I realized there's a
lot of character development over those
movies I Tyler Perry has said he's not
gonna play Mindy any more one more movie
is one more name madea's family reunion
of family funeral you know yeah alright
hey Madea mark continue um I picked the
purge because unlike scream and Texas
Chainsaw Massacre the first scream is a
zeitgeist movie that is one of the still
watchable and groundbreaking and
brilliant and arguably the best directed
thing but scoop with Wes Craven did in
his entire career and probably the best
thing Kevin Williamson ever wrote Texas
Chainsaw Massacre I argued this last
time when we were talking about
franchises to sell that episode the
first Texas Chainsaw Massacre is a
classic as a genre stablish for the rest
of them as you said are the same thing
an awful but the purge had nothing the
purge was what if we could kill people
because we didn't like people and that's
I can watch that on Fox News there's
nothing it's torture porn adjacent it's
it's it's just the same beats with
characters that are so thinly drawn you
wish Ghostface or Leatherface would show
up and kill them because at least
there'd be somebody interesting in these
movies when Frank Grillo is your anchor
in star you're French I should probably
be buried it's a divisive not funny not
clever torture porn II franchise that
that now has a TV series and explicably
and is actually worse than the screen TV
series which is blow low-hanging fruit
it's just there's there's no there there
at least with these two they sprang from
something great this was just this was
just leftover garbage they put on film
all right somewhere Frank Grillo is like
what I do all right find it out he'll be
fine
no I actually have to disagree with you
mark in that there's no there there I
think that the purge franchise had the
potential to be one of the greatest
freight hauler franchises and genre
franchise ever now I will go to bat for
the first but not the first purge as in
the title but the 2013 purge yes yes but
I do like the first purge and I'll get
to that a second but with 2013 the purge
I actually think that movie is a lot
better than people give it credit for
and I do think that where they took the
franchise in terms of a different year
and a different style of film was very
smart
it has had misses for sure but the
potential to tell an incredible story is
still there yeah and that's why it
should not be buried if anything they
should keep trying because we could
still really get the cusp of getting six
of them in a TV series they've done for
them and well don't forget Fast Five
that when the franchise turned around
and I think perch has the potential this
is the only one out of all three choices
that has the potential to actually do
some exploration I think the only
problem with the purge franchises if
they just changed the writers I've had
the same writer for all of them James
demonaco and literally if you look at
like the consensus for the last three
they're always like the mid 50 range of
Rotten Tomatoes because they're just
right there they always have a cool new
set up have a new idea and there's so
much you can do with like sociological
socio politics psychological elements
and the movies always are about to get
there so they're just look how many
bites at the Apple do they get well
demonaco did not direct the first the
first purchase and the one that came out
recently so the title is the first purge
recently yes he did and I think that
that is a great step in the right
direction visually I loved the first
purge and also some of those
performances were fantastic now I know
it's a controversial movie in terms of
this actual story but you know using
that franchise to have these
conversations is desperately needed and
at the end of the day that is what
horror is supposed agree with you that
horror can be a political thing you know
it's like we might as a living dead as a
response to the Vietnam War and a killer
clown with our killer clown in office
but I think the purge I think it's I
think you're both smart and you're
projecting stuff on there it's there you
could say that the ingredients in
McDonald's can make a gourmet meal but
they don't make them at McDonald's and I
don't think the purge that potential is
just laying fallow it's we're projecting
our own socio-political stuff and our
own ideas about what that would be like
in the real world but that's just from
the concept the movie never pays all
that the idea is talked a lot about the
purge I haven't heard a scream I really
like I think I don't think we need a
sequel for scream right now and I don't
think we need any more Sidney Prescott
movies but I got to disagree about the
shows I think I think you can fact check
this lawn
I believe the season 2 of scream this
show I know that's not the movie but the
franchise was still continuing in that
department and the questions about what
franchise should stop that got a high
critics score and a high audience score
and I believe season 1 also got a high
audience score showing that those those
shows the show was receptive and you
didn't need Wes Craven to direct every
episode and it also has a bunch of
different writers working on that show
so you can take the concept of screen
and still continue well because scream
is about commentary on horror movies and
as long as horror keeps continuing you
can still do commentary
scream is not about commentary on horror
movies that is definitely a feature of
the first handful of screen movies but
but that is not what that franchise is
about regardless I think that scream
that on television has proven to be not
the success that MTV wanted in that
rebooted their reboot so clearly
something is not working but I want to
go back to Texas Chainsaw Massacre
because something that you said earlier
was that nobody is nobody's really
interested in these movies and the fact
of the matter is in 2013 when I would
argue our current horror Renaissance
kicked off Texas Chainsaw Massacre was
the one that blew the doors off of
January 2013 with a huge box office so
the appetite is still there for that
franchise and honestly as you know and I
know you know you know a lot of people
read tobe Hooper's first movie as a
commentary on sort of like the despair
the differences between class and like
the idea that you know we're you you you
know these kids come into this world
that they don't particularly understand
and and are confronted with with this
different type of lifestyle and I think
if anything that is a brilliant thing
that we could easily explore it may be
in them if you got a director like let's
say Alex aza like he did with Hills Have
Eyes and reboot that I think you just
happy he we could really do something
with gentrifying that part of Texas just
keep rebooting the same movie don't do
it even the remake didn't do anything
that different other than aesthetic
there was really nothing a plot point
story wise they're all be exact for
development about the character of
Leatherface and I don't like the remakes
or the sequels at all but there's more
development about of Leatherface is a
character then there is Ethan Hunt in
the Mission Impossible Leatherface
origin movies and not one of them
commits to being an origin
alright let's shift gears no to final
thoughts Clark okay so I I feel like the
purge is untapped potential I like the
first purge movie and I like the first
purge and and I think that there's
something really important there and
same with Texas Chainsaw frankly I think
if you go back to those roots that tobe
Hooper established there is some
brilliant commentary on class and and
and and in the South where I am from and
and
whole mess of other things but at the
end of the day scream as I have
mentioned you know the movies I would
argue sort of dwindled in quality over
time and and with the TV show they
literally just rebooted the TV show that
was the reboot clearly this franchise
without the magic of Kevin Williamson
and the magic of Wes Craven just isn't
worth continuing so at the end of the
day let's let this go let's create
another slasher killer that wears a mask
and stalks teenagers like it's literally
every other slasher movie the thing that
made scream important and made it stand
out is is is attached to Kevin
Williamson and Wes Craven and at the end
of the day Wes is gone Greg okay I think
I think if he did scream movie every
five to ten years it would be good cuz I
personally believe that one of the
biggest coolest things about the screen
franchise is the fact that it does do
commentary on horror movies today it's
not a spoof of them but it is a
commentary on them I think that's why
scream 4 is better than scream 3 scream
3 came a little bit after scream 2 but
then they waited a while they did four
and four definitely got a more positive
response as opposed to three I also
think the show's definitely got good
audience scores so I mean maybe be on
MTV wasn't a good idea but as far for
the people who watched it they liked it
the purge is the only like scream is the
best franchise out of all three of these
franchises screams the one that actually
has a pretty good amount of good
material consistently the purge movies
is the only one that actually would make
sense to keep having sequels I think
like like what you're talking about
what's going on in the world today I
mean everything about like what's going
on with gun violence lately and how the
purge can if they just teetered a little
bit more in the end it's like got a
different writer you can do so much
awesome exploration it sets itself up
with this really cool concept in world
and that's why audiences keep tuning in
for it because of the fact that it's the
only one there that really has potential
for sequels Texas Chainsaw Massacre
there have been eight of these and they
drastically keep declining in box-office
return no I can't think the only good
one is the first one and and they
unlike the perch which has changed up
its directors and they got a new
creative people on it scream which has
had a little bit of a success with
audiences with having different creative
types on the show the Texas always
changes it up and they never deliver a
good movie because there's simply
nothing more to tell with it other than
what the first movie gave mark and Draco
um you know I think I think the fact
that if you do a top 10 list of horror
movies from most critics and most dire
horror fans both scream 1 and Texas
Chainsaw Massacre will be on there this
is a fun it's a this is a passable
franchise it's it's mediocre at best all
this is all the stuff we're putting into
it that they're putting into it about
commenting on society and stuff now is
never touched upon there this this this
show this movie series and the TV show
fetishized violence and fetish and
glamorize that it's it's it's hostile
adjacent whereas I think screams should
be put on hold for a while but I would
like to in 10 years see the kid who
first the first horror movie he saw was
scream and the meta take then I think we
need time for this one part arguing
about you I want to write the one about
gentrification in Texas now because
there's something new there this is just
one night a year people are gonna kill
them kill each other and there's gonna
be the inherit political stuff that we
bring into it ourselves but you're
bringing that on as an audience members
it's never touched upon in the film it's
just grind house stuff and there's no
central character there's nothing to
latch upon other than it says one night
it's just an utterly unsatisfying
marginal horror film that is is it gonna
be is not going to be remember these two
films are have classics and might both
need breathers but I want to see these
there's nowhere to go with this we're
gonna do for a purge it's now a week
it's now Arbor Day it's now this it says
it's just it's just a one note thing
with diminishing returns purge Arbor Day
coming soon
ring-a-ding-ding that is round two all
right let's see who we're gonna bury and
lawn facts and also give us your
thoughts on the round quickly with facts
season 2 of scream tomato meter rating
83% audience score 78% a lot higher than
the first season so Greg was right there
are some fans of season 2 of that show
there are eight total films in the texas
chainsaw series the most recent one was
Leatherface which was released last year
that was a prequel to the 24th of the
1974 original and there are
purge film so that doesn't on fact this
was tough guy I various points during
this round I was ready to give the point
to each of our three fighters I don't
think anybody got blown out I think they
all made compelling arguments but it
eventually did come down at the end
I thought Gregg had a really great final
comment and I thought he really did kind
of have arguments that knocked out the
other two purged they've never done a
good one at least spoiling marks line of
thinking I kind of liked the first four
as well but so there's room to to use
that and then the same thing with scream
like well it could be relevant because
there could be new commentary on our
movies so I thought Texas Chainsaw takes
this one you know what I've similar
thoughts to lon
I feel like good arguments were made as
to what we would want to see from the
purge how it there is more to be
explored there and then the fact that it
seems like people are still enjoying
these like scream and different
incarnations I felt like that was like
just an interesting thought to be had
there and yeah Greg you just you kind of
bludgeoned us with the chainsaw of like
oh it's the same thing over and over
again and you got me not wanting to see
it anymore the most so I got to go Greg
as well so Greg takes the point there
Danielle what's everybody saying all
right so we've got Texas Chainsaw
Massacre with 47% 26% for the purge and
25% for scream over are other things
that have been mentioned a lot of people
say saw is dunzo oh yeah a lot of people
are also real over Chucky now over on
Twitter at Corin underscore w says the
Amityville franchise needs to be buried
out of the 20 ish sequels adaptation
spin-offs direct-to-video stuff she's a
different work there's everything maybe
two decent movies the rest have been
total dumpster fires give it up already
and shut it down I'm also hearing rumors
that there's someone watching us right
now while like they're there while their
wife's having a baby so
20 minutes I should have picked the it's
a live franchise congratulations dropped
me as if you're not if your hands are
free yeah
congratulations out there it looks like
we're gonna have a new little owl on our
hands a new foundation what do you call
a baby owl I feel like that oh yeah get
back to us with an outlet and outlet
that that's adore bees a new little
outlet alright it's an outlet you're
gonna outlet right at the point you get
the you get an owl nation point all
right so it's Greg to Clark and mark
looking to get on the board here we go
with round number three Ralph breaks the
Internet did big business over the
weekend surprisingly beating out Robin
Hood
that's a franchise that needs to go away
yes so we asked you woo this is a fun
one pitch a Disney Princess team up
movie pitch a Disney Princess team up
movie all right Greg yes it's a cool if
I just to read my log line yeah
based on the same Disney Princess role
as in Ralph breaks the Ennis breaks the
internet breaks the innocent predicts
the Internet Maleficent along with the
help of other Disney animated villains
breaks into the Marvel section and
steals Thanos's Infinity Gauntlet after
she uses it to snap away all the princes
the male princess so she and her cohorts
can finally prevail against the pesky
princesses the princess says who so long
relied on their men like Aurora Snow
White Cinderella and Belle must form an
alliance with the tougher princesses
like Mulan Maria and the things they say
at Moana to exact revenge against
Maleficent and her league of villains in
my movie that I call vault Disney whoa
all right great coming in with vault
Disney and ambitious team-up mark mine
is a sort of Ocean's eleven meets
Fantasia it's all the Disney Princesses
all the villainous is who have been
killed or vanished in all the other
movies have gone to the Balrog and made
a deal with him to take all the
princesses from the girl so they can be
their male
so they're them they're the screaming
women in jeopardy they're the Fae array
and all the different princesses all
have a different skill set have to
figure out have to come together and
figure out a way to break into Bald
Mountain and not only save their men but
defeat the devil and you it's a crosses
over the different the different
boundaries you could do multiple types
of animal rock cousins but you embrace
the history of Disney going back to they
have you know what advice I would use is
they have to get the magic mirror they
have to steal the magic mirror from the
print from the Evil Queen from Snow
White because that was the device to get
in to bring the Chernabog out there and
capture all the princesses and by
flipping it on their heads by having the
men be the women in jeopardy and the
women team up and rescue them in a caper
that has some supernatural stuff and
some fun stuff all right thank you
Clark so my pitch is a little different
than than there's uh my pitches that
Belle and tiana team up together and
they go they become pirates and we
reboot the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise with Belle and Tiana and they
go on an exploration around the world
together being pirates landing in
different ports exploring going on
adventures and there's a fun cameo by
Ariel who has now been turned back into
a mermaid so she so she's there and she
says hello okay find it out okay
gentlemen
I got it I got a I'm sorry I don't want
to play this card in in a disrespectful
way but literally both of your pitches
are about the girls saving men why what
why why is this our why is this what the
princesses have to do I am just like
flabbergasted esteem oh it's a princess
tema move exactly so can we hang out
with
them rescue and save the boys like I
just feel like if we're going to
actually do a princess team up movie we
need to actually dive into what they're
interested in and something tells me
that it is not rescuing semester them
rebooting Pirates of the Caribbean for
me it's not about them rescuing the men
because they're defined by their men
that's that's flipping the archetypes of
the hero's story where there's always a
damsel in distress
women have to come together with all
their different skill sets and they all
like in the Ocean's eleven franchise
they all get a spotlight of what their
skill sets are in team up and it's
empowering they don't need they don't
because they love it you know I
understand but but my argument is if
we're gonna do a princess movie like
it's about the princesses I don't think
we need the princes to be honest that's
the story I want to see I want to see
more with Tiana I want to see more with
Belle I want to see them bonding I want
to see them having action-packed
adventures you're gonna that are not
tied to at the end of the day we have to
bring the men back the big part it's
like maybe that the end goal they like
the final moment is there but it's not
like there's you're saying the end goal
and final moment in your pitch is the
they rescue the men no I don't know they
rescue the men my say they rescue the
people they love that's not that's not
their way down to a very generalization
of both of our ideas really it's about
the inner life of both of ours we're
gone we're talking about the journey and
the interaction and the things they
learn from each other and go again
well you're bringing it right back to
them good I feel like Clark made a great
point we've we've also we've rebutted it
a bit let's move on to we're going in a
circle now okay well the reason that I
want to do a pirate princess team up
movie is because so
with both Beauty and the Beast and with
Princess and the Frog a lot of people
argue that come the second act both of
those leads kind of get sidelined right
tiana turns into a frog and and and and
Belle essentially the movie becomes
about the Beast and her rehabilitation
of the beast but I think at the end of
the day these two characters are some of
the most fascinating and interesting and
compelling characters that the Disney
Princess like stable has put out and so
by teaming them up together and having
them sort of leave out or leave out of
the Port of New Orleans and set sail for
the high seas you get to see and you get
to see something I've never seen before
which is honestly like a badass pirate
movie that has ladies in it that has
ladies up at the central focus and you
get to see a completely like unique
adventure for these two princesses see I
think I think that there's something
there's something about that that's
interesting but it's just the two
princesses you have I want to see later
yes a cameo she's Mike Myers and but I
want to see the Avengers with these
princesses if the record Ralph scene did
for me was like I want to see all these
women get together and do something and
kick some ass because they're saving
their men it's not a message where they
need their men to define them that's
like saying well you know in Star Wars
they say Princess Leia is that what does
their end goal they're just saving a
girl if you flipped if you flip those
genders in that it's if the argument is
just I think very it minimizes like you
said all of the villains we know who are
the villains that you're Zola the Queen
from Snow White all of them from yeah I
mean I mean from my idea what I wanted
was like you start off with the four who
are known to be like self-reliant or not
known to be self-reliant like the ones
who clearly are all about their prints
and then when they go on their journey
they have the team-up with the tougher
ones like Mulan Merida from brave and
and when they do that it's like they
learn from each other that this though
once we're not so self-reliant learned
to be tougher and the ones who are
tougher learned to be a little bit more
sensitive and I feel like you can have a
lot of fun quipping back and forth and
then they go on their journey like my
idea is the Infinity Gauntlet that was
the Maleficent took is put under the sea
that's being guarded by Ursula so they
have to like get mallanna's help to go
to to the CRL is like still a human it
got kind of what Clark actually had I
have it written down here too it's like
are you know still a human and then the
end she does come in and like helps the
whatever the kingdom is where the
mermaids are and then you have like a
big epic battle between all of them like
all the deal like the Disney villains
and they're all [ __ ] your final thoughts
sure I basically think that with this
idea it's like so if they're not by a
couple things I base I think that this
story idea that I have lint lends itself
to a structure that is easy to see where
you can actually have a lot of fun
interaction with all the Disney
Princesses you know it's like these
characters will learn from each other
it's really about their arcs where the
sensitive woman learn to be you know
more tough and self-reliant where the
tough ones learn to be you know a little
bit more sensitive so it's not attacking
the Disney characters but showing that
all the qualities of self-reliance plus
vulnerability coexisted already within
all of them one thing I liked about that
Ralph breaks the internet cameos I did a
great job at poking fun at a lot of the
Disney Princess tropes that I've been
criticized but they didn't insult the
property and I want to carry that theme
forward and I also think what there are
us would be fun to have a cool musical
number and and I think that with Clark's
idea I think there's some interesting
elements there I don't really see a full
movie laid out though it's more of just
an idea and I also think that you know
parts of the like rebooting pirates I'm
sick of pirates why would we want to
just reboot that right now and for
Mark's idea it's like yeah I know we
have a lot of similarities I feel like
yours is a little too dark for my taste
for Disney Princesses teaming up alright
yeah
no he has Thanos his glove kill half of
the Disney animated character so sorry
mine mine too
I think I think for mine I want to see a
superteam movie of all these cool
princesses because I think we're Clark
and I agree but we don't realize we
agree is I think the princess that
princes are generally bland guys no one
remembers the prick that's what was so
great about Kenneth Branagh
Cinderella I understand why she loves
this character I think on paper you you
run a slippery slope of maybe making it
the trope of rescuing people but I think
these women getting together and proving
to themselves that they don't need the
men and they're viable potent characters
and rescue they're rescuing people they
love they're not rescuing men as agender
I think that is a noble thing that is
the goes to all the hero's quest and I
think it ties in all these great
characters and we've seen the success of
the DC superhero girls the kids where
where the Disney Princesses are pretty
dolls and you have the you have these DC
superhero girls that are like kick-ass
superheroes and high school and stuff
you can do that with the Disney
Princesses make them not make them more
Megan Merkel as a princess then Kate
Middleton as a princess make them
someone who's a person who's good who's
got a personality and defined and I
think it would be a lot of fun to see
all of these characters will be the best
kind of nostalgia thanks mark
Clark okay so at the end of the day for
me the problem with these other two
pitches is that however you define it
they're tethered to the women's
relationships to the men and I don't
think we need that frankly like I think
these characters are interesting enough
to stand on their own and again I chose
to to focus on two because I think that
if we because I actually want to see a
movie with folk that focuses really
focuses on these two characters I also
think that it's time to swing big I
don't want it to be this this you know
cool role reversal that we see in
Hollywood all the time like like oh you
know that trope well we're flipping it
it's like yeah but we've seen that
before
what we haven't seen before is is in
swashbuckling action-adventure starring
two women who are learning about each
other and who are setting out on their
own adventure for themselves so that's
why I want to see that movie awesome
Thank You Clark ring-a-ding-ding that is
around three long I we handled the
Chernabog thing so I don't really
it affected a lot of people in the
comments were pointing out cutthroat
island as a female-driven
I think you also have Matthew Modine I
think Clark's point still stands so I
would not offer that as well so
cutthroat island is a notorious horrible
movie so I I don't I'm not gonna include
Renny Harlin must be so distraught right
now come on Chyna so cool yeah
cutthroat island Geena Davis Geena Davis
is great oh no I'd like you guys to know
enough love out there so uh yeah this is
a fun round yeah uh maybe the most
interesting thing to me was stealing the
Infinity Gauntlet
but that um I like that a lot
he's talking about me first guys yeah I
felt like these like super team team ups
like it's stole a little bit of the
individuality of the characters and the
princesses and I like how Clark just
like really have like made distinct
choices for a reason and and I like I
feel like it's important to make it
their own story and I thought Clark
really hit that not that you guys like
you know we're saying they need the men
but you know the role reversal but she
had that nicely in her final thoughts as
well that that is such a common trope to
take you know someone who doesn't
usually do the thing and flip it in this
version of the story so for several
reasons yeah Clark just uh her answer
really started to resonate with me and
by the end I wanted to see that Belle
and tiana team up the most Clark gets my
point along well I really made Greg I'm
gonna talk about you first again I was
crazy about the idea of bringing sort of
the fan OHS Marvel stuff it just feels
like this is finally the Disney
Princesses chance of sighing why are we
bringing in so much Marvel stuff so I
kind of thought Clark got yeah on that
one and it's splitting our focus so it
came down to mark versus Clark for me I
will say with Clark's pitch I like the
pirate idea I just I wanted to hear more
of the pitch itself what's the conflict
what's their goal like what are they
going like this is their own adventure
but because I do feel like most movies
like that there would be a love interest
there
be some part of the goal that would be
involved with either men or women if
that was their interest so I that felt
that's not weird it just felt like she
wasn't giving us necessarily the
conclusion to avoid that so ultimately I
felt like I was gonna go with mark all
right so it's 1:1 mark and Clark
Danielle what does the poll have to say
um with 41 percent it is mark Greg has
33 percent and then Clark's idea with 25
percent one tweet I really wanted to
point out that I liked it's from one of
our regulars hey dude I'm gonna do the
thing I do where I make it so your name
isn't the cuss word you're trying to
make me say get underscore [ __ ] Eve says
milada and Ariel the ocean masters which
I think it'd be interesting and then he
invites Aquaman a second well mallanna
is already a navigator so that is an
interesting point she wouldn't wouldn't
she be one of the pirates y'all ready
dangerous to see one of them the best
friends with the hurricane wash up on
her island oh I like that yeah well our
speed round is set everybody this one
came down to the tiebreak and Mark just
by a hair is moving on
oh Clark well fought man you know III
loved your last answer and I just your
answers throughout I thought you really
brought it today and I'm sorry I'm not
gonna see in the speed round but please
come back and kick all of them's asses
next time around because it's always
great to have you I gotta say it's
always hard to compete against Clark
because we are on the same team in the
Schmo down and she's so smart and so
biting and specific and great that it's
always a pleasure isn't pietatis oh ya
know she put my mind to like a whole new
way of looking at Princess Leia today so
for that and for just you always coming
in and bringing it and after that spec
Texas Chainsaw Massacre script awesome
but this here is a great moment in
sports because this speed round will
decide who will face Dan Moreau for the
title belt all right
um so this is how the speed round works
we'll throw out the question shout out
your answers the first person to answer
will get a chance to elaborate on their
answer first it will give me 20 seconds
20 seconds and then 10 second rebuttal
10 second rebuttal fellas y'all ready
for this yes sir all right first
question of the speed round
okay keepin it keepin it dis keepin a
Disney the first travel for The Lion
King dropped on Thanksgiving is it fair
to call the new Lion King movie live
home damn it okay mark says no and Greg
says damn it okay so mark will argue for
no Greg will argue for yes and mark 20
seconds begin whenever you speak there
is no live action in that movie it is
all computer-generated it is animated it
is animated there's no argument there
this question I don't even have to argue
because there's no live action and it
it's all CG I don't know why we call
realistic animation live action it's it
makes zero sense it's derivative it's
it's insulting to all the animators that
made all that stuff look real insulting
to animators Greg while it's heavy on
CGI there's still plenty of sets that
are being built there's still a lot of
crew members that all involve bringing
it to life so yes it is CGI but that's
also like saying those sequences in
Avatar are not live-action and only
animated just because there's a lot of
CGI doesn't mean it's strictly animated
the fact that there's so many people on
set that is mocap involved these are
real people bringing this to life ok
avatar by the Academy rules would
qualify as an animated movie and mocap
has existed Peter Pan all the flying was
done with rotoscoped is that not an
animated movie because they used that
it's a it's an invalid argument to
animate a moving
I don't know about Avatar being
qualified as an animated movie but the
fact that Disney itself is calling it a
live-action movie qualifies it to be a
live-action movie the fact that you have
directors actors onset people building
sets it's live-action movie all right
Daniel Radford I just really want to say
great job Greg and arguing something but
a very and a great argument on
considering how vehemently disagree but
yeah I got it yeah mark came with the
facts he came with yes it is insulting
to animators yes there has been a
history of using rotoscope like in the
beginning of Jem I don't know why I know
that and the mocap has existed and the
thing about the academy rules is what
put it over for me okay that's one for
mark you know what I'm gonna make it two
for mark mark you just tied this ball
game up let's go on to question number
two and we're tied two-two first player
to four takes it hugh jackman will go on
tour next year singing from greatest
showmen lame is Rob and more what movie
star would have the worst touring live
stage show Russell Crowe does it have to
be someone alive now I'd say no yeah I
don't think so yeah the worst touring a
live show words were story why is this
singing life or just like alright
whatever you want Charlie Sheen alright
Charlie Sheen we heard Russell Crowe
first 20 seconds again when you speak
Greg lame is is a classic musical play
that requires you to be a fantastic
singer and then the movie is delivered
on fantastic singing and the biggest
thing I heard before I ever saw that
movie was how horrible Russell Crowe is
in that movie every time he was on
screen and seen it ruined the film it
takes you out of it so for him to
revisit and tour that since this wasn't
specified as a singing tour Charlie
Sheen actually did this once and no one
cared he is a drug
misogynist who's dying I don't want to
pay $80 and spend two hours watching him
tell stories about his drug addiction
and all the porn stars he's had sex with
that sounds like the most depressing
thing in the world and these Russell
Crowe is an oscar-winning actor what was
the question again
okay the question is what movie star
would have the worst touring live stage
show people love watching Charlie Sheen
go crazy and do stupid things in front
of the public he was he that's
catapulted his career to something even
bigger Russell Crowe if he was to do
some type of live performances singing
again just be awful Charlie Sheen is
considered a joke by everyone that
actually matters Russell Crowe is an
Academy Award winning actor who gave one
of his best performances recently and
has interesting stories to tell if you
see him on talk shows and he tells
stories I've listened to him time wow
I'm slightly confused by the question is
it is it Tiger blood or is it Tigers in
the gladiator arena that didn't work out
okay the way they're long tough one I
feel like I feel like I feel great did a
good job of convincing me why I wouldn't
want to go see Russell Crowe sing but
the question was just live stage show so
I think on that level mark Turkey all
right that's one for Mark Daniel Radford
I have to agree with everything that lon
just said we are not stepping on this
one yep and I would have been clean
sweep on that yeah mark and Draco's
vaulted into the lead 3 to 2 on the
shoulders of Sheen hashtag winning yeah
ok question number three this is game
point for mark by the way right you need
this to keep her going thanks how sure
thing in their online store a 24 is
selling scented candles inspired by
movies on Rah's which movies candle in
any movie which movies
candle would smell the best the Cheech
and Chong series which movies candle
yeah agent truckers they're all odd the
Corsican brothers don't pick the
Corsican born in East LA okay that's all
right I think of it yeah we've amped
enough for a branch give us an give us a
candle way off make it a candle just
think of a movie movie candle oh I think
like a candle from an actual movie
smelling hands yeah this movie man it
like became if they made a candle based
on 10th of a woman you know I would like
to enjoy a lovely evening with both of
those cat makes the other great yes all
right and both make a wonderful
combination alright so we heard mark
first Cheech and Chong up and swung I
think it's I think it's funny because of
the marijuana Association but now as
marijuana and cannabis and CBD have
become more accepted culturally are used
as medicine and the smell of that when
you walk past someone smelling some good
smoke and some good herb that's a good
relaxing smell and I think it ties into
their brand the brand of what Cheech and
Chong are alright mark keep it up 420
friendly Greg I know so many people who
hate marijuana and hate the smell of we
you have to have a very specific taste
or something like that
we're Scent of a Woman when I think
about that movie it is constantly about
scent and pointing out beautiful
smelling things so I feel like if they
were to do candles based off of the
beautiful things out Pacino is smelling
throughout that movie the beautiful
perfumes even get candles
there are so many different smells to
the different sense the different
strains of marijuana some of them are
actually quite floral and fly fragrance
so writing them off as the bud we used
to smoke in high school is it
diminishing instead of a woman that
title alone
title alone woman who smelled great
smell great it's a lovely scent what I
think we both smoked marijuana
apparently and I think that all
marijuana smells exactly the same I
every time I go buy some it's like the
exact same thing right I'll talk to you
after the show
all right time the most ridiculous
question ever asked thank you that's the
point yeah I felt like Greg had a good
ding on mark saying yeah most of
marijuana smells pretty similar whereas
any painted the picture of just not you
know of Pacino finding different scents
and essences so for that I'm gonna go
with Greg lon
yeah when he first said it I thought we
were going down a real questionable Road
but Greg totally brought me back around
with the you know it is a scent themed
movie so I'm going threat there we go
pick a movie what candle Steel Magnolias
oh yeah you know I wish I could give
Clark the point okay here we go it is
all tied up at 3:00 3:00 this my friends
is game point yet again a great moment
in sports if they remake back to the
future who should play the new Doc Brown
Michael J Fox
richard jenkins we have Richard Jenkins
we have Michael J Fox mark twenty
seconds on the clock one sister since
this is never gonna happen because the
mecca said oh won't Michael J Fox would
be playing the Doc Brown type he would
be taking over the role like charlie
takes over the Chocolate Factory which
would give this franchise instant
validity and the fans like me who think
this is a perfect movie and should never
be remade but if you did having Marty
have all the knowledge of Doc and having
to be the mentor would be a lovely
lovely evolution of him and a great
salute to Michael J Fox will it me the
question more time please yes if they
remake Back to the Future who should
play the new Doc Brown you didn't treat
yours like a remake you traitor like
your own little sequel movie that you
want to do and I have members watching
Michael J Fox do that Jimmy Kimmel thing
and it was not easy to watch like the
both of them are just can't really do it
Richard Jenkins though I remember saying
him in shape of water he's good at
playing like neurotic older guys he
could bring some it's a little bit more
subtle really believable to talk Brown I
want to remake this with Richard Jenkins
as he can be the whole neurotic guy this
is such a beloved franchise that you
have to have an acknowledgement of it
and this isn't a reboot this isn't just
a this is a reboot conceptually but it's
also a through-line of continuation and
I think that's the only way to if you're
anything a consider doing this you
clearly don't want your movie to be made
I want my movie to be made Richard
Jenkins is that older actor who can
bring so much subtlety to I think
Michael J Fox taking over this without
having this Christopher Lloyd
counterpart is just a distraction in
missing element time alright Danielle
sorry I take notes while you guys
arguing so I can make it fair
yeah both of these are great arguments
it really does come down to the question
of whether it's to take over as actual
Doc Brown or take over to dr. Doc Brown
type I am I didn't see there being a
problem with it being a doctor on type
and therefore I I do have to say that I
like marks pitch better alright so that
is one for mark with Michael J Fox
yeah I man I I thought Mark had a good
pitch and I really liked it just like
being in omage and a connection that the
fans would accept but then yeah
Greg brought up that jimmy kimmel
parents unlike that was at the 25th
anniversary of Back to the Future and
it's yeah it was it did feel a little
ham-fisted it didn't it wasn't
satisfying was kind of like oh okay
great and I do love Richard Jenkins
who's great in shape of water love that
guy since uh six feet under and I need
and the visitor and so many great movies
so yeah I'm going with Greg so lon
comes down to you my friend both
interesting takes when when Mark first
said Michael J Fox I wasn't quite sure I
saw it but I did like sort of how we
talked through it and and what the
actual pitch was but ultimately I think
if you're gonna reboot back to the
future just got a clean slate it trying
to do something totally different with
it and I thought Richard Jenkins is a
really interesting outside the box way
to go with it so I'm going with Greg as
well Greg you take the day GTE and Joe
star putting that out there right now
well Gregg you will fan and for what
it's worth I completely agree remarked
on that best bet not to make it but yeah
you take you took the day you will face
Dan Merle for the belt Gregg give some
shoutouts tell us where we can find you
all that good stuff youtube.com slash
the real rejects I was a little nervous
today because I'm pretty tired I thought
there was a special Marvel movie trailer
dropping yesterday so I prepped I put
together a sketch with my buddy and so
keep a lookout for that trailer review
cuz it'll be a sketch at the top of that
but I want to say thank you screen
junkies for bringing me back here I've
watched like the whole sju universe and
that's Ju you know yesterday I watch all
of sju so I love being here and Clark is
someone and Mark is all some people I've
liked see all the time online on the
Schmo down and everything a movie if
I've seen all your movie Fight this this
year and it's like so cool to be just
here on this panel with you guys like
you both are people that I really admire
and it's not easy admitting when I'm
nervous I was like just fake confidence
the whole time and so I'm really glad
that I can be here with you guys today
and how thank you so much oh of course
and guess what Greg there are people
watching the show right now we're saying
the same damn thing about you sir
because you come in here and you really
give it your all and you show off your
knowledge awesome having you well played
Clark you're the best you always come in
here and like you're you're smart great
points thank you so much for just yeah
being a friend of the family please give
some shoutouts yeah thank you for having
me you can find me on instagram and
twitter at clark wolf Clark with Annie
will Fellini all right Clark wolf thank
you Mark and Drake a well-fought you
took it to the limit and came up just oh
man just short but mark you're always
great tell us some stuff that you're up
to I'm reading Supergirl monthly for DC
I have another big DC project it'll be
announced probably after the holidays
and there'll be a big announcement in
the New York Times tomorrow about the
next recipients of the lavas love
donation for this year oh wow that's
that's awesome yeah if you haven't
please check out his Eisner
award-winning venture love is love what
an awesome cause weight loss in print
you can get pretty copies at Amazon or
do
it's also there are seven foreign
editions around the world and at this
point the book in all its incarnations
have raised about $400,000 for charity
amazing mark good stuff sir ah la
terrasse holding it down the facts as
always find me on twitter at l ons and i
write a newsletter about what's
happening in streaming TV and film you
go to inside.com slash streaming and
subscribe to that Thank You long Thank
You Danielle Radford hello thanks for
being on just our ray of sunshine and
being the voice of the people ah thank
you the people make it easy when they
make it easy and I love the people yeah
you can nugget me you can find me uh at
Daniel Radford on Twitter if you like
wrestling I have a wrestling podcast
called tights and thighs and the max bun
network I've been writing more stuff for
fandom so you'll be seeing some of that
coming out soon and you can file in my
patreon where we talk about wrestling
and now we're doing a lot more movie
stuff and I would love to see you guys
over there wow Thank You Danielle owl
Nation hashtag owl nation hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram
we'll talk movies we'll talk TV we'll
talk Al's we're Micha hooligans at I
want to thank you for watching movie
fights again Greg will see you in a
championship match coming up soon I want
to thank Billy biz jte and everyone that
helps put this together thank you again
for watching bye bye
[Music]
you